excellencies
ambassadors of the eu member states
officials from government of india
ceos from private sector organizations
and members of media it is our proud
privilege to welcome president of
european union commission her excellent
name is ursula fondo lion to the
international solar alliance
headquarters we are equally grateful to
the president of international solar
alliance assembly minister of power and
new and renewable energy government of
india his excellency mr raj kumar singh
for joining us this day
ladies and gentlemen we are witnessing a
landmark even today for the development
of solar energy around the world i
welcome you all to isa headquarters on
this very special occasion without
taking any time further i would like to
invite director general international
solar alliance dr ajay mathur to present
the opening remarks please
madam
it's such a pleasure to welcome you it's
really an honor for us
i am delighted that you have found time
in your schedule to grace this occasion
i also express my gratitude to the
president of the isa assembly and the
minister for energy
the indian minister for energy mr rk
singh to be here with us
i'm also delighted that the secretary of
the new and renewable energy ministry
the european ambassador and ambassadors
of the member states the european member
states who are members of the isa
have also come
here today i thank all of you for being
with us on a sunday
ma'am
in the past few years we have seen a
huge growth
in the solar industry
in the past
10 years the amount of money that has
gone into the sector has gone up from
something like
less than
approximately 50 billion to more than
200 billion
this reflects the changing solar energy
panorama
and
consequently because of commitments we
are seeing greater investments occur at
the isa we are striving to accelerate
solar power uptake in every corner of
the world with a special emphasis on
sunshine rich
the least developed countries in the
small island developing countries and
mobilizing a trillion dollars worth of
funding for solar investments in these
countries
ma'am
this isa resonates with the european
commission's spirit of no person and no
place left behind
our efforts under our three pillars
of programmatic support capacity
building and analytics and advocacy
and our nine thematic sectoral programs
are guided by a similar principle
we strive to employ solar technology to
drive equitable impact across all the
105 member countries who we have with us
today
we note that in all of our at least in
all of our developing country members
the here and now needs of our member
countries are important and we need to
ensure
these needs are met as we move along
we also resonate with your ideals
of behind the
africa eu partnership
it bothers us
and
the
president of the assembly has often
mentioned this that there are about 600
million people in africa who don't have
access to energy and yet
last year just 4.7
of the solar investments went into
africa we need to work together to
ensure that the
we maximize the benefits to the african
continent in particular while minimizing
environmental threats
we look forward to work with you we have
a joint declaration
and to see how we can enhance our
partnership we are grateful for the
1 million euros of support that the
european commission has provided and we
look forward to
the formal request that we have made for
a pillar assessment by the european
commission to enable direct support to
the international solar alliance
we are working on various kinds of
things but i'm adam i think where we can
work particularly is on issues related
to the disposal
of the solar panels and of the batteries
which have lived out their lives
that together with
enabling generation across the world i
think would be necessary for us to
ensure that solar reaches every part of
the world
we will work with you to making solar
energy affordable
accessible and equitable and look
forward to
strengthening this cooperation that we
have with the european commission and we
wish to make it stronger thank you very
very much
thank you dr mathur
may now request secretary ministry of
new and renewable energy government of
india mr industry vedi to present his
remarks please
her excellency ms ursula fonder leon
president of the european commission
honourable mr rk singh president of isa
general assembly and minister for power
and renewable energy government of india
dr ajay mathur director general of isa
excellencies ladies and gentlemen this
is a short function so i'll be very
brief in my remarks
first it makes us
let me just let me just make four quick
points one
it makes us happy that the president of
the european commission commission is
amidst us today
isa was set up with lofty ambition
on the initiative initiative of india
and france
and it requires solid commitment from
isa members
to achieve this high ambition
and i think this visit of the president
of the european commission to isa
headquarters is an indication of the
collective collective commitment of eu
member states to isa and its cause
two the eu is a valued partner both for
india and isa
the ministry of new and renewable energy
which i represent
is seeing overwhelming overwhelming
commitment
and energy
toward the green energy transition in in
several of the eu eu member states
and there is also growing interest in
partnerships with india
in this in the area of renewable energy
i think this is an extremely positive
sign as there is much we can learn from
each other i believe there is similarly
a progressive strengthening of eu-isa
partnership which has immense potential
for benefiting both sides
three
india remains steadfast in supporting
the isa we have worked to strengthen isa
ever since its inception and will
continue doing so that said i think it's
also important to highlight that
strengthening the isa is a shared
responsibility of all its members
individually as well as collectively
and fourth and last i say today is at a
stage where with a little support from
its members it can take rapid strides
towards fulfilling its charter this
would of course require continued
commitment and hard work but the initial
foundation has been laid and i commend
both the president
director general
dr ajay mathur and the first director
general dr open triparti for their
leadership in this regard thank you
thank you mr chaturvedi
i now request a president of the isa
assembly minister of power and new and
renewable energy government of india his
excellency mr raj kumar singh to please
present his remarks
excellency
the president of the european commission
the members of a delegation
ambassadors
the secretary ministry of new and
renewable energy
mr industrial satellite the directorate
general ms sajay matru
members of the industry ladies and
gentlemen
it's a pleasure to welcome you
excellency here
and we believe that your visit
is an indication
of
the concern which the european
commission has
with reference to our climate with
reference to energy transition
and with reference to
the need
to providing access to millions of
access to energy
for millions of people worldwide
that is how
i will see it
excellency
the problem of confronting us
confronting the globe
is not something which can be solved by
one country alone
and it is not a problem
which
will go away
if one country
goes green entirely or if one country
gets to net zero or even if for large
num even if 10 countries or 20 countries
get to net zero
the problem will not go away because it
is one world and it is interconnected
it's just like covid
you can't have
country wide solutions you have to have
a worldwide solution you have to have an
international solution because
i mean
emissions knows no boundaries it goes
around the world
therefore we have to tackle emissions
worldwide and we believe that
the major part of tackling emissions i
mean that's the philosophy which we have
as a country now as a country
we are committed we are committed
despite the fact
that our per capita emissions are
one-third of the world average despite
that
for us environment is impo for us it is
essential to leave behind a healthier
planet for
the following generations now so we have
been working at it and
we can share the experiences which we
have gone through i mean and we have
been working at it i think faster than
almost any other country in the world
we have added
163 gigawatts that's 163 000 megawatts
of renewable energy capacity i mean
non-fossil fuel capacity which is about
41 42
of our generation capacity now this is a
target which we had set for ourselves to
be achieved by 2030. we've achieved it
by november 2021 that's the pace of
change which we have said
uh
and
we
have not stopped i mean we
can't we you know we have upped our
ambition in our in glasgow we decided
that
we'll increase our installed capacity of
non-fossil fuels uh sources of
electricity to 500 gigawatts which is
about 500 000 megawatts
now uh we've also decided that we'll
reduce
our emissions intensity by 45
by 2030. now we had pledged in paris
that will reduce our emissions intensity
by 33 percent we
already neared that we are already near
about 30 or that's our estimation so
we'll cross that again much before 2030
that's why we upped our ambition in fact
we are the only country only major
economy whose actions are consistent
with the sub to degree rise in global
temperature and all this despite the
fact that our per capita emissions are
as i said one third of the world average
but in this journey we have had some
experiences and i would like to
share those experiences and what lessons
we believe that holds for energy
transition around the world now we talk
about net zero and we talk about energy
transition but
the problems which are inherent inherent
in net zero and energy transition
need to be taken note of and need to be
addressed
one of course
is storage
now the problem with storage is you
can't have you can't replace fossil
fuels until less we have round-the-clock
renewable energy and you can't have
around-the-clock renewable energy
excellency until unless you have storage
now there are two predominant forms of
storage one of course is pumped hydro so
that is something which
we are exploiting but that is limited
limited by location etc the volumes are
large
and
economically it works out cheaper than
the battery storage but
it is not mobile and
it is stationary and it is limited by
the
geology or the geography etc
the other of course is battery storage
now the present price cost of battery
storage is about six us dollar cents per
unit but that's expensive that's
expensive when you consider that the
price of solar today
is about
three us dollar cents in fact less than
three us dollar cents so if you add
storage of about six us dollar cents the
price of electricity goes up to about
nine us dollar cents which is
difficult for poor people to afford so
we have to make storage affordable now
that requires volumes that requires
investment in volumes that requires
investments in manufacturing
unfortunately not much has been done in
that today the largest storage which
exists around the world is just about
400 megawatt hours that's the largest
which exists
now we have
come out with a bit for a thousand
megawatt hours so this by far the
largest in the world and we propose to
come out with a bid for 2000 megawatt
hours now what needs to be done is for
other developed countries also to start
adding scale because if all of us start
adding skill then the price will come
down but here i let us just mark this as
a challenge for energy transition now
why i'm coming to this is because that's
our mission in the international solar
lines our mission in the international
social analysis number number one to
provide electricity access to
electricity to the
millions of the deprived people around
the world and do it in uh by
in a way that does not harm the
environment that is by using solar power
which we believe is cheap is plentiful
it's uh
if it is available everywhere
it's even available in ladakh in fact
our
not the most reason has the most solar
installation and we believe that that is
something which can actually sort out
the problem which our planet is facing
now uh so one problem which we i mean we
are facing it but we have the money i
mean
our country doesn't need any support so
we are adding storage but when we are
talking about round-the-clock renewable
energy in africa and countries like that
they will need support they will need
support for
storage because storage is not going to
be
affordable by them i mean we find that
we have you know we have to give
vgf when we are adding
you know
storage otherwise the price of
electricity will go high
that vgf
you know
we can afford
but
the poorer countries i think they'll not
be able to afford that so we have to
worry about that
the other thing is we which
we have to
worry about
is about and that is again something
that is an advantage which we had as i
said you know we have added about our
capacity uh non-fossil fuel capacity is
163 000 megawatts uh out of which if you
leave out nuclear
which is about six thousand seven
thousand megawatts so the non-nuclear
renewable energy uh is about 157 000
megawatts
so that and that capacity
out of that capacity you know our solar
and wind energy etc would be around
110
000 megawatts would be solar envelope
give out hydro now that capacity we have
not had to invest money in because we
hold bids and people come and invest
but you know for that to happen so i
mean we haven't had to put out any money
for that and the investments are coming
i mean even during covid even in 2021 uh
our invest the investments the fdi
foreign direct investment in our
renewable energy capacity was 11 billion
dollars even even during profit so we
are still adding capacity renewable
energy capacity but that won't happen in
africa
investment will not come so that is
again something which we have to think
about now why it won't happen in africa
is because people need
investors need security
they you know this is something
adding renewable energy or adding
renewable energy capacity is something
which can be done
which private which companies will come
and invest in in all sectors i mean in
generation private sector
people will come and invest that's
what's happening here that's how we've
added that capacity uh
private sector investors come and invest
in transmission now that is what is
happening here we added and we've
connected our whole subcontinent size
country into one grid running on one
frequency it's the largest single
unified grid running on one frequency in
the world so now we can transfer about
112 000 megawatts from one corner of the
country to another
at
a single frequency but
now a large part of it was done by the
private sector we hold bids they come
and invest they set it up and they get
tariff
but that won't happen in africa so there
then similarly distribution
i mean distribution is again something
which the private companies do and can
do so that can also happen in africa but
then again all this points to the need
for a guarantee fund credit guarantee
number one there has to be a credit
mechanism now we heard heard a lot of
talk about you know
money being put aside green funds for
100 billion dollars etcetera nothing of
it is metallizing now if it doesn't
materialize
i mean the world will go on i mean it
will go on
so long as we live and maybe for the
next generation rejection thereafter
that but after that
and it's not going to get solved just by
talking
you need we need to put aside a credit
guarantee fund and we need to put aside
mechanisms for providing financing at
low cost to companies which go and
invest in africa
now that is a challenge before us
what
we are doing
in the international solar alliance is
that we are
sharing our experiences
with the countries and helping them to
design systems design systems which will
make generation
commercially viable which will make
transmission commercially viable how to
structure it which will make
distribution commercially viable all
that will happen all that will happen
but
it only
if only if we provide a credit guarantee
fund so that is one of the i think major
requirements
and
i believe that all of us
have a mission or need to
think ourselves responsible for setting
up these
because that i believe that is i believe
where the challenges
uh that is i believe where the challenge
for energy transition and therefore for
climate action is
and it's going africa is going to grow
it will grow the emissions will grow
and unless and until we start putting in
place mechanisms to make sure that that
growth
is a green growth you you will have a
huge huge continent size
uh
you know mass which
which will be
whose emissions will keep increasing
therefore
thereafter it won't matter whether you
know some country goes to net zero and
some in 2035 or some country goes to net
zero in
20
50. now another thing about now so this
is one part of it
the second thing of course is you know
the hydrogen now green hydrogen is again
something we are
investing in we have come out i mean our
prime minister has almost a green
hydrogen measure that has huge potential
huge promise the cause again is
something which will have to be
addressed this before their developing
countries can access it and that is the
cost of electrolyzer water they have
plenty the cost of electricity now the
cost of electrolyzer will also come down
again if we add volumes that again is
something which we are going to do as a
country we can afford to do it our
market is used therefore
you know when we say that you know we
want
so many thousand megawatts of
electrolyzer capacity people will come
and set it up here we'll add volumes but
it won't happen in africa so i so that's
what that was one of the reasons why we
set up this alliance the international
solar lines so that all the countries
come together and solve each other's
problems in order to provide access
uh we've done that
we've provided we've connected 28
million homes
ensuring universal ass but it is
possible and i think it is easier with
renewable energy is easier with solar it
is easier with solar because solar
enables distributed generation so it is
easier with smaller
and
we would expect the developed world
i mean who
seem to be now very committed i say seem
to be very advisedly
then i'm known to be a blunt person i'll
remain what i
am so they or the developer seems to be
committed to energy transition and to
reducing emissions but if that
commitment is actually
going to be
real then these are the things which
need to be addressed and we expect the
european commission to be a large part
of it thank you excellence
thank you very much your excellency
it is our privilege to now invite her
excellency ms ursula fonder lion
president of european commission to
address the gathering please
thank you very much excellencies mr
president and your minister
ambassadors
um distinguished ceos
thank you very much for welcoming me
here
and for organizing this roundtable
and i'm very pleased to visit the
headquarters here of the international
solar alliance
this is not only
because the international solar alliance
is one of india's flagship initiatives
to fight climate change as we just heard
but also because the business case of
what you're doing has never been better
than today
and those who embarked in that topic
20 25 30 years ago would not have
thought how dominant this business case
right now is
and therefore india and the european
union are closely aligned
in the fight against climate change and
of course have understood
how precious
solar energy is
both
india and the european union have
embarked on their way to net zero
europe wants to be climate neutral by
2050
and india by 2070
but in addition
india has committed to cover half of its
energy demand
from renewable sources already by 2030
this is amazingly good news
this is very ambitious congratulations
but it's the right way to go
europe and europe we've set ourselves
similar goals so we know how difficult
it is to get there but you have to be
ambitious
in these times where climate change
is showing us every day
what
happens if we don't work against it and
if we don't come up with innovative
affordable
and effective solutions
and both india and europe
know that solar energy will play a
decisive role in that
so the need for clean energy
was never more obvious than today
indeed in india people suffer from
extreme weather i read that the march
this year
was the hottest march
since 122 years
but i can tell you we do have the same
experience of course in the european
union droughts
last summer deadly floodings
wildfires hurricanes in regions where we
never ever had these extreme weather
phenomenons and you all know
this is the beginning of what climate
change shows us of extreme weather
conditions
that will become more intense
if we don't act decisively
and as we know
that climate change is man-made
that's bad news we've done it but it's
also good news
we can fix it if it's man-made
so you know that the
the
authority and science of climate change
the ipcc
has just said that to prevent the worst
effects of climate change
emissions of co2 would have to peak
peak
within the next three years
so at the same time our demand for
energy is drastically rising you were
describing it and in india
energy use doubled in the two last two
decades and it will continue to grow i
want to say
this is first and foremost
good news
because it shows that india's economy is
doing well
with all the benefit that it brings to
citizens all across the wonderful and
vibrant country you have here so it's
good news
but it also of course shows the urgency
for the transformation
to
clean
and sustainable ways of doing business
and using that energy
because we all know that this energy
this additional energy that you will
need
has to be clean has to be green
we can do it there are options you
touched on many of them
but it needs an enormous amount of
determination on the political part of
investment on the public and on the
private side
so we have to step up our efforts in the
energy transformation and initiatives
like the international solar alliance
are key to this
there's a second reason
why the switch to
homegrown clean energies is so important
in these days
and of course i'm thinking about the war
that russia has unleashed against
ukraine
for us europeans
it is a stark reminder
that our dependency on russian fossil
fuels is not sustainable
because how can you do business with
someone
who openly threatens europe
and wages war
against one of your closest neighbors
so our transition
to
homegrown
renewable energy
is not only good for the environment
but it also becomes a strategic
investment in security
energy policy is also security policy
because every kilowatt hour of
electricity we generate from solar wind
hydropower or biomass
reduces our dependency on fossil fuels
in general
so this is why the european commission
will present next month a new solar
strategy of the european union as part
of re-power eu we can discuss it later
on in the round table if it is of an
interest
and here too
india and the european union are on the
same path
prime minister modi has announced that
india should be energy independent
before
it celebrates
100 years of its independence as a
country
this would be in 2047.
so it's in our common interest
that this independence
of fossil fuel
that comes from abroad
is a transformation into renewable and
clean energy
as you know the european commission has
always been and will always be a strong
supporter
of the international solar alliance
since it was created at the cop21 in
paris in 2015
and i commend the work that the alliance
is doing to develop new technologies
this is amazing what you're doing
you're scaling up solar applications for
agriculture
extremely needed you are accelerating
the production of green hydrogen with
solar energy you spoke about it and we
can go in depth in our own table
you're capturing the infinite energy of
the sun and making it to all
available
and affordable
there will not be a green transition if
it is not a just transition
if we are not able to leave nobody
behind but to take everybody along
so what you're doing is innovation put
at the service of people
and i'm really interested to hear from
you from business from you who are
active in the solar energy sector about
your experiences but also of course
about your vision the opportunities the
difficulties let's talk about it
the eu india clean energy and climate
partnership was adopted in 2016.
as you know we discuss a large variety
of important issues there be it the
smart grid source storage the clean
energy financing
our cooperation on green hydrogen a big
topic for europe
but my visit also shows me
and all the discussions that we have
that there is so much
untapped potential
so we can do so much together to improve
the situation
we need to step up our cooperation
we can learn from each other how to
finance promote and deploy solar energy
how to secure global supply chains big
topic since the pandemic when we learned
what it means when all of a sudden
global supply chains because of the
pandemic were interrupted with all the
consequences
and the material of course needed for
solar panels
how to identify the best areas to place
those panels fields land or rooftops etc
etc
together
we can indeed increase the economies of
scale and scope the minister you raised
the topic
the economy of scales and scopes
in tapping
the power of the sun
we should do this through the
international solar alliance
and there's a second point
that we should have a look at and this
is mission innovation
mission innovation is a global
initiative of 22 countries and the
european union
together
they represent more than 90 percent
of global government investment
in clean energy research and innovation
with mission innovation we want to
accelerate the innovation in clean
energy everywhere on our planet
and india is a key
key contributor
to this common effort
the ministerial in india will be next
year it will be an important milestone
because mission innovative innovation is
the place where our cooperation with
india
and other partners is moving the
frontier for clean energy so as i've
spoken about the untapped potential
here's the place
to really draw on it and to develop the
common projects
that will
forge the path forward to the future
i want to raise a last topic
because you rightly so mentioned
the potential of the african continent
and indeed
there are massive investment needs
that we discovered also after or
during the pandemic
not only in the european union not only
in india
but also around the globe in the
developing countries
and therefore the european union has
developed global gateway
a 300 billion
heavy investment
initiative
where the focus lies
on
green
initiatives
of course there's second focus on
technology
the digitalization
and the third one on resilience but the
main focus
is on the green deal
and here 150 billion
are tailored for africa
to indeed do exactly what you said
they have an abundance of natural
resources
for green energy
but they need the investment and it's in
our common interest
not only to develop but also to store or
to transport
these clean energies
so also here to work intensively
together
to understand
the signs of time
and to
take this potential that is out there
and really to do something about it what
is critical for our fight against
climate change that is the task of today
so there's a much we can there's much we
can achieve together boost our economies
for us the european green deal is our
new growth strategy
because we know if there's a future for
the economy it's going to be a circular
economy if there's a future for energy
and we need energy it has to be clean
energy
if there's a future for a way to produce
and to consume we have to change it
into the patterns of a green
transformation but this is our new green
and growth model that we believe in the
international solar alliance is
emblematic
of the kind of partnership
we need to make this change happen
because we all have our place under the
sun
and we will do whatever it takes
to keep this planet livable thank you
very much and i'm looking forward to the
discussion
thank you very much your excellency